I think actually that people are are
quite hard on themselves and you know
this is one of the reasons that I
believe that the presumption of
innocence that characterizes our legal
system is such an absolute bloody
miracle I cannot figure out how in the
world that idea ever came about and
developed universal acceptance it's so
unlikely you know if you deal with
people in a clinical setting and they're
somewhat depressed which is not uncommon
and they've done something that they are
guilty about independent of whether
they've done something that they feel
they're actually guilty they tend to
take themselves apart now that's
especially true if you happen to be high
in trait neuroticism which is one of the
big five traits extraversion which is a
positive emotion dimension neuroticism a
negative emotion dimension agreeableness
which is compassion and politeness
conscientiousness which is orderliness
and industrious and
openness which is intellect and openness
proper something like creativity if
you're higher than normal in neuroticism
it's very easy to take yourself apart if
you're feeling guilty about something
that you've done and people many people
will feel guilty about what they've done
at the drop of a hat I mean first of all
they accuse themselves of their own
shortcomings and then if they are
accused by someone else it's often very
very difficult for them to mount their
own defense you know to believe in their
own innocence
you know because you'd think well you
know the police come to your door or a
mob comes for you let's say on Twitter
and you know your stalwart sort of
person and you pronounce your innocence
and you know you're a you're a brick
wall nothing gets through that and
that's just not how it goes man if the
mob comes from you for you on Twitter
the probability that if you're a
reasonably well socialized person that
you're going to be wondering what you
did wrong
how you should apologize and what you
should do to put yourself back in the
good graces of the community is
extraordinarily high
you know because well you you probably
have done some things wrong in your life
and you probably are guilty about this
and that and perhaps you didn't conduct
yourself perfectly and so it's very
difficult for you to mount your own the
defense to presume your own end of
innocence and mount your own defense
which by the way is why it's a very good
reason to have a lawyer and one of the
things I would say I'm dead serious
about this I've worked with legal cases
a lot and learned a lot about the
limitations and lack thereof of police
ability to question you for example and
if you're ever accused of something
serious then do not talk to the police
until you have a lawyer because you will
definitely get yourself in all sorts of
trouble and so you might think well if
you're innocent and the police will tell
you this too then you have nothing to be
afraid of
of course that's complete bloody rubbish
because you always have something to be
afraid of and innocence and guilt are
relative things and they're not that
easy to determine so don't be so sure
that you can defend yourself especially
for four reasons we'll go into but also
don't be so sure that you don't need
someone who's professional to stand sort
of outside of you and to look at you
like an individual among other
individuals and to adjudicate your
relative guilt or innocence in that
manner you know in our legal system
you're actually not required to be
perfect and thank God for that
what you're required to be is reasonable
and like like a reasonable and let's say
somewhat normative human being you're
not required to go above and beyond the
duty with regards to heroism for example
I was involved in a court case it was
quite a terrible case where a woman was
up on trial for murder and she happened
to be in the wrong
at the wrong time shall we say she was
in a Motorhome in a junkyard waiting for
her boyfriend and she happened to walk
out of the motor home just as a gang was
killing an enemy I guess an enemy gang
member with a with rocks very very
brutal and they stripped her naked and
told her that they would rape her and
that they would kill her child she had
one child unless she participated in the
murder and so she did and she ended up
dropping a rock on the unfortunate
gentleman's head although by all
appearances he was well on the way to
being dead at that point and at that
point in Canada the law was there was no
excuse for participating in homicide
regardless of the what would you call
ameliorating preconditions but they did
decrease her culpability substantially
because they believed there was genuine
reason for her to believe that her life
was threatened and that she was going to
be subjected to sexual assault and that
her child I don't think they did
threaten her child but they did
certainly threaten her child with no
longer having a mother so in any case we
can get involved in very terrible things
and it's it's very difficult for us to
defend ourselves you need a lawyer to do
that and so that's a good piece of
practical advice and I would strongly
recommend that you follow it if you ever
happen to find yourself in trouble it's
also the case if you find yourself in
trouble at work or on social media you
know it's hard to sit and remind
yourself that you deserve the benefit of
the doubt and then to try to make a
coherent case for that one of the things
I often did for my clients who were in
trouble at work for one reason or
another often because well for a variety
of reasons sometimes because they hadn't
done everything they should have that
work and
so they carried some burden of
responsibility for that but sometimes
because there were people who were
genuinely malevolently predisposed
towards them bullying them in terrible
ways and they just weren't good at
mounting their own defense which was
also one of the things by the way that
made them prone to being bullied and so
we would work for hours on at least
hypothetically outlining a story that
involved the possibility that the person
who is being accused so that would be my
client was actually innocent of the
charges you know and that's that's
something that's useful to do for
yourself if you ever run into trouble
it's you don't have to believe that
you're innocent to begin with but you
could make the strongest case possible
that you are right because everyone's
entitled to a strong defense and then
just see how that flies you know see if
it's coherent I mean you could make the
opposite case - just so you know what
you might be in for but you know we have
an adversarial system for a reason and
part of the reason is is that one of the
easiest ways to get at the truth insofar
as that's possible and that's not an
easy thing is to attack you know with a
certain degree of intensity and
viciousness and defend with a certain
degree of intractability and and and and
coherence and you need both of those